RETO MEIER: Today, we're
talking about machine images,
deployment pipelines,
and the dashboard API.
I'm Reto Meier, and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Compute Engine now
offers machine images.
Machine images contain all
the instance configurations
and metadata for
your virtual machine.
That means creating,
backing up, and restoring
virtual machines is
easier than ever,
even if you use custom images,
because properties like machine
type, network tags, and
labels, and so on are all
captured in a single resource.
Google Kubernetes Engine
just got an upgrade
with automated
deployments that require
no management or updates.
The pipelines are
powered by Cloud Build
and run automatically
when changes
are made to the source code.
You can even
preview a deployment
from your pull request
to verify the change will
work as expected.
Try it for yourself, and
let us know what you think.
The Cloud Monitoring
Dashboard's API
was released last month to
help you create dashboards
programmatically.
A practical use case here is
taking an existing dashboard
and using the API to
recreate it across all
of your other workspaces.
And that's exactly why one
of our solutions architects
created this walkthrough.
Migrating a monolith
is best done in stages.
To see why that's true
and how to best move
through those stages,
check out this tutorial.
It covers how to migrate
using Google Kubernetes
Engine from prep work
to dependency analysis
to real-time migration advice.
Brought to you by your Get
Cooking in Cloud hosts.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see the full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.